sur quelque 15000 taxis parisiens en
compte et voici un an à peine 70
chauffeur femmes
on en compte 500 aujourd'hui
ce qui n'est pas pour déplaire à la
clientèle masculine ainsi le fait est là
absolue officiel la femme s'est bel et
bien installé au volant et il nous
apparaît urgent de recueillir là dessus
quelques témoignages capitaux
le chiffre est un producteur parisien
vous diront les actes et les défenses
elle ce que vous passez de la conduite
de la femme au volant à l'odieux moi
j'aime les femmes partout au volant ou
ailleurs un semi la mienne je viens de
lui acheter une petite voiture 2
millions 400 mille francs
elle y tient beaucoup ça fait huit jours
qu'elle l'a elle n'a pas encore perdu la
clé j'en reviens pas
il y à un starter cesti pratique ça me
coûte 20 litres au cent oui je sais le
rétroviseur ça lui rappelle son cabinet
de toilette la boîte à gants son armoire
à linge
elle navigue bien sûr parfois
r&b à genoux mais quand les vitrines le
mérite
elle sait prendre son temps d'ailleurs
elle conduit si bien que tout le monde
la regarde
monsieur vous qui pratiquez la codi
sportive il ya vous nous dire ce que
vous pensez de la police rémy mine quand
il fait mine pas c'est pas moi c'est un
petit peu gênant parce que présentant
une masse a par exemple son mari vient
d'acheter une voiture oui voilà ce qui
forme des scellés sur les démons
allez ça arrive en débat la bonne voie
mais pour se replonger
alors les rup devant sur le trottoir
l'arrière il fait ce qu'il peut
alors pas plus d'accidents que les
hommes beaucoup parce que
un peu réduite ils font attention où
c'est sensationnel c'est la descente de
voiture
ce que alors là mais c est votre opinion
sur la config féminine
ça me gêne un peu je peux vous parler de
ma petite amie elle s'en sort très bien
jolies jambes un rouge feu vert elle
mélange tout regardez-le avec la force
publique
elle s'en sort pas mal non plus
oh ça conduit demande pas de fantaisie
du verre et qui la pousse à charleville
la galanterie c'est fou même la bonne
et sa place préférée c'est à côté de
moins à une façon de conduire tellement
douce ya pas mon volant on vous en
parlait justement de rencontrer
[Musique]